à côté
ryan webb xvii de couleur à l'on veut
c'est
il y a moi
[Musique]
brito pour eux ont
Oui
plus de pression
lit et non il aimerait sans photos audio
le sourire
Miami
il avait même l'inégalité à la place
harmonica
à WhatsApp
maison inc.
[Musique]
john huston et vieux sprays ou
intellectuelle au-delà du record du monde
aussi avec tous les temps
s'il vous plaît oui euh mot de l'armée de l'air
dit monsieur
est
dit michael sinclair et si c'est michael
frayn
l'ami de la foule
un V
[Musique]
Je suis Alberto, celui dans la pièce, pas moi.
Reconnaissez-vous pourquoi avant j'étais gros et
Agnès
la fille d'une femme en ce moment
faisons une fête
Salut
pau ne sera pas une fête de bienvenue non
es-tu enceinte as-tu encore
petit ami, que pensez-vous que nous avons été
ici dix ans à attendre son retour
couleur non mais oui il parait que je te connais
de tout ce que je t'ai vu qui attrape
a votre facebook donc maintenant vous avez
seins et [ __ ] et que j'ai tout
tu es entrain de faire
tu m'as laissée enceinte et tu as disparu
tourné
[Musique]
Je pense que ta mère est le poulet qui a
donné de la nourriture à miami à peu près comme si elle
il aurait dit encore qu'il a mangé
beaucoup
Merde, nous sommes à nouveau une famille
[Musique]
avec tant de lesbianisme par ici, eh bien, quoi
Je suis curieux, voyons
si ce n'était pas une insémination artificielle
Alors qu'est-ce qu'une [ __ ] mais qu'est-ce que
était une fois que vous êtes une [ __ ] est d'avoir le
visage de nier ce qui était entre
vous tous
tu me touches le cul
Quel passe-temps avez-vous tous pour que je sois lesbienne et
quelle manie de tout étiqueter javier
les blancs ne continuent pas à marcher pas avec tant
les gens d'un ici personne ne part c'est
ravie qu'elle soit mon amie et ex-petite amie
à cause du visage en colère qu'il a, il savait
que je ne pouvais pas faire confiance je me dévoue
Je me sens super identifié avec tout
cette